the medical model that I began to talk
about this problem based model is is
really restricted it's very powerful and
it helps us but but it only takes us so
far the fundamental nature of dying is
not medical it's personal and so you
know dying cannot be encompassed by a
set of medical problems and a set of
diagnoses and treatments so while we you
know while we can can remain disease
focused for as long as it makes sense we
also have to attend to the personal
aspects of dying people you know the
what you lose and dying in the hospital
many times is you lose that personal
time your your your space is not your
own people walk in and out you don't
have this sort of privacy or intimacy
with family beyond that though we
staying within that medical model
everybody who walks in your room or
interacts with you are talking to you
about medical problems they will
continue to conscript your attention to
the lab tests and the next scans and the
next treatments and the drugs and your
vital signs and all of that instead of
attending to the personal they actually
can script your time and energy for the
medical the best end-of-life care that i
know of through modeled by hospice
programs and and the best palliative
care programs still does all the medical
stuff but it's subordinated to the
personal it's it's you know when in
hospice care we make appointments to see
you and your family not the other way
around we're coming to your home we are
explicitly acknowledging the importance
of interactions of your privacy and
intimacy and beyond that we're even
offering some help some guidance that
may be a value to you in this area of
humor
interaction i would call life completion
in life closure you know which again in
a problem-based medical model doesn't
even exist it's not their quality of
life and quality of life completion
really exists in a developmental model
that really honors the the breadth of
human life for the person and family but
but not in a problem based model so even
the very best of problem-based medicine
and including attention to symptoms in
the like tends not to see those personal
experiences of completing ones you know
affairs fiscal and legal and project
related affairs but also their personal
affairs their their relationships their
explorations of their own meaning and
significance of their own life their
relationship to something larger than
themselves that stuff that's not
abstract for people who know that that
their life is measured in weeks or days
it's it's very tangible
you